Hook angle look me hook come here. You could do the carousel
To switch and wrap
- 40 % 160
I just want to take care of my grandma. Maybe go shopping every once in a while
When I was a kid, I always wanted to work with animals. I was close
These Wall Street guys, you see what went into this country. I stole from everybody
Hard-working people lost everything and not one of these douche bags went to jail
The game is rigged and it does not reward people who play by the rules
It's like robbing the bank except you get the keys
Are you in
These are my coworkers
What if somebody calls the cops and says what?
I spent five thousand dollars at a strip club send help
We're family now
Would you say that things got out of control
So the guy went back three more times he must have liked it
We didn't do anything wrong, you know, Tony wouldn't let this happen I'm gonna text him gave her her phone back